Cada lata de sopa,
cada trozo de carne, cada camiseta.
Como humanos, ahora mismo,
estamos destruyendo lo único que necesitamos para sobrevivir:
nuestro planeta.
Y la mayoría de los problemas horribles a los que hacemos frente hoy,
como el cambio climático
y la esclavitud moderna en cadenas de montaje,
vienen de decisiones.
Decisiones humanas de producir algo de una forma y no de otra.
Y así es como, como consumidores,
acabamos tomando decisiones que dañan el planeta
o a nuestros colegas humanos.
Eligiendo productos incorrectos.
Pero me niego a creer que cualquiera en esta sala,
o francamente, cualquiera en este planeta,
realmente quiera comprar un producto,
que dañe el planeta o a los humanos
si se le da la elección.
Pero verán, elección es una palabra de peso.
Elección significa que hay otra opción.
Elección significa que pueden permitirse esa opción.
Pero elección también significa
que tiene suficiente información para tomar una decisión informada.
Y esa información a día de hoy simplemente no existe.
O al menos es de muy difícil acceso.
Pero creo que esto está a punto de cambiar.
Porque podemos usar la tecnología para solucionar este problema.
Y muchos de los aspectos tecnológicos que necesitamos para hacerlo
se han vuelto mejores y más baratos en los últimos años,
y ahora están listos para usarse a gran escala.
En los dos últimos años,
mi equipo y yo hemos trabajado
con una de las mayores organizaciones de conservación del mundo, la WWF,
y fundamos una compañía llamada OpenSC,
donde SC significa "cadena de suministro".
Y creemos que usando la tecnología
podemos ayudar a crear
transparencia y trazabilidad en las cadenas de suministro
y a través de eso, ayudar a revolucionar completamente
la manera en que vendemos y también producimos como humanos.
Bien, algunas cosas van a sonar un poco a ciencia ficción,
pero ya está ocurriendo.
Déjenme explicarles.
Para solucionar este problema de información,
necesitamos hacer tres cosas:
verificar, rastrear y compartir.
Verificar la sostenibilidad específica
y la proclamada producción ética
en una base de datos y de manera automática.
Después rastrear estos productos físicos individuales
en las cadenas de suministro,
y finalmente, compartir esa información con consumidores
de forma que realmente les dé una elección
y les permita tomar decisiones de consumo
que mejor se ajusten a sus valores.
Voy a usar un producto real
y una cadena de suministro donde hemos hecho esto realidad:
la merluza negra patagónica
o bacalao chileno, como es llamado en EE. UU.
Número uno: verificar.
Verificar cómo es producido algo.
Pero no solo diciendo: "Confía en mí, esto es bueno,
confía en mí, hemos hecho todo bien",
sino creando una evidencia para ese producto físico
y la forma en que es producido.
Creando una evidencia
para un producto específico proclamado sostenible y ético.
Así que, por ejemplo, en el caso del pescado,
¿ha sido capturado en un área donde hay suficientes,
para que sea sostenible atraparlo allí
y no en un área marina protegida?
Lo que estamos haciendo aquí
es tomar los datos del GPS del barco casi a tiempo real,
el barco que está pescando,
y nos dice dónde está el barco
y dónde va, a qué velocidad.
Y entonces podemos combinar eso con otros tipos de datos,
como, por ejemplo, cuán profundo es el lecho marino.
Y combinando toda esta información,
nuestra máquina de aprendizaje de algoritmos puede verificar,
automáticamente, si el barco solo pesca donde se supone o no.
Y como los sensores se han vuelto baratos,
podemos colocarnos en más sitios.
Y eso significa que podemos capturar más datos
y combinarlos con los avances en la ciencia de la información,
que significa que ahora podemos verificar
productos específicos proclamados sostenibles y éticos
de forma automatizada, en tiempo real y continua.
Y realmente eso sienta las bases de esta revolución informativa.
Número dos: rastrear.
Rastrear esos productos físicos individuales
de manera que podamos realmente decir
que la afirmación que hemos verificado sobre un producto
de hecho, pertenece a ese producto individual
que como consumidores tenemos frente a nosotros.
Porque sin ese nivel de trazabilidad
todo lo que hemos verificado en primer lugar
es que alguien, en algún lado, en algún momento
capturó un pez de forma sostenible
o no perjudicó al empleado cuando les pidió producir una camiseta,
o no usó pesticidas que de hecho no necesitaba cuando cultivó un vegetal.
Solo si le doy una identidad a un producto desde el principio
y lo rastreo a lo largo de la cadena de suministro
se puede mantener la afirmación
y el valor que dice tener al producirse de forma correcta.
Bien, he hablado sobre los sensores baratos.
Hay muchos otros desarrollos tecnológicos
que hacen que todo esto sea mucho más posible hoy que nunca.
Por ejemplo, la bajada de costos de etiquetas.
Se le da a un producto un nombre,
un número de serie, una identidad,
su etiqueta es su pasaporte.
Lo que pueden ver aquí es una merluza negra siendo capturada.
Esto es lo que se llama pesca de palangre,
los peces entran en el bote en anzuelos individuales.
Y tan pronto como el pez está a bordo,
se le mata, y tras eso,
insertamos una pequeña etiqueta dentro de su carne.
En esa etiqueta hay un chip RFID con un número de serie único
que acompaña al pez a lo largo de la cadena de suministro
y hace muy sencillo detectar su presencia
en cualquier puerto, camión o planta de procesado.
Pero los consumidores no pueden leer las etiquetas RFID.
Y así, cuando se filetea y empaqueta el pescado,
leemos la RFID y la quitamos.
Y entonces añadimos un código QR único para empaquetar el pescado.
Y ese código QR señala la misma información
que hemos verificado sobre el pescado en primer lugar.
Y así, dependiendo del tipo de producto con el que trabajamos,
podemos usar códigos QR, códigos de barras, etiquetas RFID
u otra tecnología de etiquetado.
Pero también hay tecnologías
que están al borde de la expansión a gran escala
que dejan a las etiquetas obsoletas.
Como, por ejemplo,
analizar un producto para rastrear elementos
que pueden decir con precisión de dónde vienen.
Luego está el blockchain.
Una tecnología descentralizada que puede actuar como catalizador
de esta revolución.
Porque puede ayudar a mitigar algunas cuestiones de confianza
que son inherentes al dar información a la gente
y entonces pedirles cambiar sus hábitos de consumo
debido a esa información.
Y así, usamos la tecnología blockchain
donde damos más valor a lo que hacemos.
Pero, más importante,
no permitimos que las limitaciones que aún tiene esta tecnología,
como, por ejemplo, respecto a la escala,
se interpongan en nuestro camino.
Y eso nos lleva al tercer punto.
Compartir.
¿Cómo compartimos la información que hemos verificado y rastreado
sobre de dónde es el producto, cómo fue producido
y cómo llegó a donde está?
Cómo compartimos esta información
es muy diferente de producto a producto.
Y diferente según dónde lo compre.
Uds. se comportan de forma diferente en estas situaciones.
Están estresados y tienen poco tiempo en el supermercado.
O con poca atención durante la cena
porque su cita es una belleza.
O son críticos e inquisitivos
cuando investigan para hacer una compra grande en línea.
Así que, para nuestro pescado,
hemos desarrollado una experiencia digital
que funciona cuando compramos pescado congelado en una pescadería
que le da toda la información sobre el pescado y su viaje.
Pero también funciona con un restaurante
y desarrolla una experiencia digital diferente
que solo resume hechos clave sobre el pescado y su viaje
y funciona mejor en una cena,
y, con suerte, no molesta mucho a su cita.
Bien, eso cierra el ciclo.
Hemos verificado que el pescado fue capturado
en un área donde es sostenible hacerlo.
Luego lo hemos rastreado en una cadena de suministro
que mantiene su identidad y toda información asociada.
Y hemos compartido esa información con consumidores
de forma que les da una elección
y permite que tomen decisiones de consumo
que se ajustan más con sus valores.
Para el pez de este ejemplo esto ya está implementado a gran escala.
Esta temporada,
la flota entera de la mayor compañía de pesca de merluza negra,
Austral Fisheries,
ha etiquetado cada pescado que han capturado
y esto termina en el producto de su marca premiada "Glacier 51".
Y ya pueden comprar este pescado.
Y con esto, todos podemos tener la información de la que hablé hoy,
y mucho más,
unida a cada pescado individual o porción de pescado que puedan comprar.
Pero esto no es solo cosa del pescado o el marisco.
Sino que trabajamos con muchos servicios y productos diferentes
y sus cadenas de suministro a lo largo del globo.
Desde lácteos a frutas y verduras,
hasta productos no comestibles hechos de madera.
Como consumidor, todo esto puede sonar como una molestia enorme
porque no tenemos tiempo para mirar toda esa información
cada vez que compramos algo.
Y no espero que lo hagan,
porque tendrán ayuda para eso.
En el futuro, dejaremos cada vez más la decisión
sobre qué producto específico comprar a las máquinas.
Un algoritmo sabrá suficiente sobre Uds.
para tomar las decisiones por Uds., así que no tendrán que hacerlo.
Y quizás haga incluso un mejor trabajo.
En un estudio reciente, el 85 % de aquellos
que compraron un producto con un asistente virtual,
dijeron que, en ocasiones,
eligieron la recomendación del producto estrella
de ese asistente virtual
más que un producto o marca específica
que pretendían comprar en primer lugar.
Ud. dijo que necesitaba papel higiénico,
entonces hay un algoritmo que decide qué marca, señala el precio
o si le va el reciclaje o no.
Hoy en día normalmente está basado en qué compró en el pasado,
o en quién paga más a la compañía detrás del asistente virtual.
Pero ¿por qué no debería basarse también en sus valores?
Sabiendo que quiere comprar sosteniblemente
y sabiendo si y cuánto está dispuesto a pagar por eso.
Eso lo hará fácil y sin problemas
pero escoger los productos correctos
aún estará basado en efectos granulares y datos.
No necesariamente haciéndolo Ud. mismo,
sino preguntando a un algoritmo
que sabe cuánto se preocupa por el planeta.
No necesariamente haciéndolo Ud. mismo,
sino preguntando a un algoritmo
al que nunca le falta tiempo o se distrae
o con poco nivel de atención por una cita
y sabe cuánto se preocupa por este planeta,
por la gente que vive en él,
pidiendo a ese algoritmo buscar toda la información por Ud.
y decidiendo por Ud.
Si tenemos una fuente de información valiosa y confiable como esa
y los sistemas correctos para usarla,
los consumidores apoyarán a aquellos que hacen lo correcto
produciendo productos de una forma sostenible y ética.
Los apoyarán cada vez
eligiendo sus productos por delante de otros.
Y eso significa que bienes, productores, procesadores y minoristas
serán recompensados.
Y los agentes perjudiciales serán forzados a ajustar sus prácticas
o dejar el negocio.
Y necesitamos eso.
Si queremos continuar viviendo juntos en este bello planeta,
realmente lo necesitamos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)